alright let's get started
long time no see I'm excited to be back
and tell you guys about Bayesian
networks so before we dive in I want to
do a few announcements first there's
four things that should be on your radar
so the scheduling homework is due
tomorrow hopefully you guys are well
aware of that
the car assignment is released today and
it'll be due next Tuesday so there's
some conceptual challenges here
especially if you're not too up to speed
on your probability the section Thursday
will really help you go over that so
please come to that then there is a
final project you guys have hopefully
all received your feedback for your
proposal and are actively making changes
so just to make sure that you guys are
making progress there's a progress
report that is due next Tuesday and for
this one the guidelines are all on the
website but just to kind of reinforce
eyes especially if you didn't manage to
get a baseline or Oracle you really
expect that you to have that now and
also we expect you to have some sort of
preliminary results with you know some
sort of implementation of your actual
procedure or algorithm or model and it's
definitely some description of what that
is and be as concrete as possible as you
can
and finally the exam is in about two
weeks I would start looking at that in
the I actually the best way I think to
prepare for the exam is to look at the
old exam problems because there's a
certain style that you have to kind of
get used to when taking the exam so I
know this is a busy time there's a lot
of things going on but hopefully you
guys will manage yeah it's Tuesday I
believe but I could be wrong
yeah let's say it's Tuesday yeah it's
whatever the website says oh it does
taste Thursday okay well then we'll
defer to the website on that okay okay
so the next agenda item is the pack
mount competition so many of you worked
hard to submit various entries into this
competition
the end only three could make it to the
top three so here are the winners of the
pac-man competition
is out of town but if
in the audience maybe you guys could
come down
let's give them a round of applause and
we have these prizes which are pac-man
theme cups filled with candy in case you
didn't get enough for Halloween so there
you go congratulations you guys want to
see a little bit about what was your
secret sauce
okay well congrats hey alright so keep
it simple I guess is a good lesson okay
so back to a regular programming um last
week we started talking about factor
graphs just a quick review of what
factor graphs are factor graphs consist
a set of variables these variables could
denote colors of provinces of Australia
or locations of objects at different
time steps factor graphs also includes a
set of factors which depend on certain
sets of variables and these factors are
meant to specify preferences or
constraints on what values
are good for these variables to take on
and the weight of an assignment is
simply the product of all of the factors
right so there's a steam that comes up
in this class which is I call it
specified locally and optimized globally
right so it's very easy to think about
how two variables might interact and how
you want something local to happen and
these are defined in terms of the
factors but what you care about is some
globally optimal solution so the weight
is a global function of all the vert
assignment to all the variables and last
time we talked about various different
types of algorithms for finding the
maximum weight assignment including
backtracking search beam search gibbs
sampling and so forth and so forth okay
so one example we looked at was object
tracking and in this example we have a
set of variables corresponding to the
location of a unobserved object at time
step I and we looked at two types of
factors that captured where this object
might be there's transition factors
which capture the intuition that across
two successive time steps the objects
shouldn't move if you can't teleport it
has to remain close and observation
factors that incorporate the information
from the sensors at each position
there's going to be some factor that
kind of encourages the position to be
similar to what the sensor reading was
so sensor readings are noisy so it's not
a hard constraint but it's a better soft
constraint and last time we saw this
demo where you can define the factor
graph and you click run and you see all
the factors which are represented in
these tables and when you multiply
everything together you get for every
joint assignment to all the variables
some number that corresponds to how good
that assignment was and if you look at
the maximum weight assignment that's
what the answer you would return us okay
so so far so good and you can with this
framework you can do a lot with it
already you can define a bunch of
factors you can run all the algorithms
that we looked at last week but you know
what is where these factors mean and how
do you come up with
intuitively you can define these
factories just you know hack on a - if
you like it one if you don't like it but
you know philosophically maybe you
should be a little bit bothered by this
because these factors are kind of just
arbitrary in some sense so the goal of
this lecture and the next two will be to
give more meaning to the factors and
we're going to talk about Bayesian
networks it's a way to do that so in one
sentence Bayesian networks our factor
graphs plus probability just taken is
taking a step back where have we been in
this course this course has been a lot
about designing new modeling frameworks
so we looked at state-based models which
result in search problems and MVPs and
games and this was a useful tool for
solving a lot of problems already but
then we looked at starting last week
cases where maybe the order of actions
doesn't matter so much and it's more
natural to think about a set of
variables that you want to find some
assignment and any order is you know
permitted and you can think about that
as going maybe stepping up in
abstraction kind of going from assembly
to maybe C++ and in this lecture we're
going to talk about bayesian networks
you can think about loosely analyzed and
analogizing going from C++ to Python it
gives you a kind of a more high-level
language to think about modeling and
it's just another tool in your tool kit
okay so let's start with the basics
there's a quick review of probability
usually we've see probabilities start
with outcome spaces I'm gonna jump
directly to random variables assuming
that you have a basic CS 109 knowledge
so random variables are things in this
example are sunshine and rain so they're
variables whose values are unknown and
furthermore there is a probability
distribution over all the random
variables that captures how they might
interact and so this is called a Joint
Distribution so we write P this
blackboard P of the two random variables
and our and this is this entire table
which specify for every possible
assignment to all the variables a single
number which is its probability so the
probability that it's sunny and it's not
rainy is 0.7 for example no so I want to
distinguish two things one is that we're
going to use uppercase letters to do
random variables and lowercase letters
to denote the values that the random
variables can take in addition I want to
point out that when I write P s equals s
articles are that quantity expression
represents a single number which is a
probability for example 0.7 or is if I
write P of SNR that expression denotes a
whole distribution which is the table
and I know these are kind of minor
notational differences but I think it
will avoid a lot of confusion if you
kind of pay attention to this so from
the DOE and Joint Distribution you can
use the laws of probability to derive
several quantities one quantity is
called the marginal distribution and a
marginal distribution you pick a subset
of the variables that you care about
those are called the query variables and
you induce a distribution over them so
in this case I've picked s and what I'm
saying is I only care about the
probability of s I don't care about our
but our still has kind of influence on a
so I need to take our into count somehow
and the way I do this is I look at all
possible values that s can take on so
look at 0 and then I look over to the
Joint Distribution and look at all the
rows that match that particular s so
here I'm looking at s equals 0 so that's
the first two rows and I look at those
probabilities and I sum them up so point
two plus point zero eight is 0.28 and
similarly for s equals one I look at all
the worlds I match s equals one which is
the last two rows and that gives me 0.72
okay so what i'm doing here is called
marginally out marginalizing out our
because i don't care about our I'm
interested in the marginal distribution
over yes so another concept which is
going to be really important is the
conditional distribution and the
conditional distribution arises when
your interest when you have some
evidence so assume let's say I observe
that it's raining so R equals one
so I write P of s given articles one to
say this is the I'm interested in
distribution over s given that it's
raining and to compute this I look at
this condition R equals one and I simply
select all the rows which match that so
the second and the fourth rows so now
these are numbers now probability if
they don't sum to one right because it's
only a subset of the rows but what I'm
going to do is make them sum to one by
normalizing so normalizing means taking
the relevant numbers point zero eight
point zero two adding them up and
dividing by that number okay so I'm
dividing by point one which gives me the
normalized distribution point eight and
point two
okay so these two concepts are going to
be really important and if you remember
from last week there we talked about
marginalization as conditioning later in
this lecture I'll connect these two
concepts
any questions about basic probability so
hopefully this is all review okay let's
move on so suppose I have a Joint
Distribution over some set of variables
so then in this example it's sunny it's
raining whether it's traffic and whether
it's the autumn season the way to think
about this is as a probabilistic
database for every possible assignment I
have a number that is either is it's
between 0 1 um so I can think about this
as an Oracle this is the source of truth
I don't know what any of these variables
is but I know how they behave in how
they operate just like I know I don't
know what the outcome of a coin flip is
going to be but I know that it's half
and half heads and tails so the main
thing that we're going to do with a
joint distribution is called perform
probabilistic inference okay so this is
an important thing to you know
understand because we're gonna spend the
whole time doing probably singing
friends so it's good to know what it is
so probably this inference the way to
think about it is that you'll observe
some evidence you wake up and you see I
okay it's autumn and and it's a Bay Area
so there's traffic outside so you're
conditioning on some evidence T equals
one and a equals one okay that's what
you know and what you like to find out
according this Oracle is you know
whether it's raining so you're
interested in some set of query
variables okay so the general form of a
problem
inference a problem or task is
probability of some set of query
variables conditioned on some set of you
know conditioning variables which are
set to particular values and notice that
there are some variables which are not
mentioned in this query such as s and
those variables are the ones that are
marginalized out so you can think about
this query as combining both the
marginalization and the conditioning
from the previous slide okay so this
without loss of generality just captures
everything that we
seek to do with distribution for the
purposes of
okay so at this point you can actually
just do probabilistic inference right if
I give you a joint distribution which is
this huge table with all the
probabilities for all the assignments
you can go and you compute anything you
want so now there's a kind of a slight
problem here which is that if you have n
variables and just supposed to each
variable takes on two values how many
possible how many rows in the table are
there
anyone Judy the end right so that's
exponential that's a lot so if n is 100
and that's so so clearly we can't do
this naively right so the first
challenge is how do you even write down
this Joint Distribution compactly right
I don't want to write down to the N
numbers so Bayesian networks is going to
allow us to define Joint Distribution
using the language of factor graphs so
this is really cool because now I have a
very compact way of specifying what is
implicitly something that's very very
large the second challenge is
algorithmic how do you do inference
right we want to do perform
probabilistic inference answering
queries like this how do we do this
efficiently again you don't want to have
to go through to the end different
possibilities because that would be
really really slow and we'll see that
variable in the mayshen Gibbs sampling
particle filtering which is the problem
sick analog of beam search all these
algorithms that we talked about last
week are actually going to come into
play and we're just going to talk about
the probabilistic analog of these as
opposed to finding the maximum or yes
I'm okay
so now let's try to motivate why we need
Bayesian networks with this following
example so here's a setting so
earthquake earthquakes and burglaries
are things in the world they're bad
things but suppose that they're
independent right that kind of makes
sense but in your house you've installed
an alarm system which is going to detect
either both earthquakes and alarms okay
so one day you wake up and you hear an
alarm go off okay so you should be
alarmed but but then you turn on the
radio and you hear that there's actually
an earthquake so how does that affect
your beliefs about whether there was a
burglar or not okay so okay there's
three options does it increase the
probability of a burglary there's a
decrease of probability of burglary or
does it not changing okay so how many of
you think that hearing the news about
the earthquake on the radio increases
the probability of a burglar so you see
increases how many you say it decreases
so many of you say it decreases how many
say it doesn't change hey almost as many
say it doesn't change hmm okay that's
interesting so we'll answer this
question but you know keep on thinking
about that in your back of your head and
one thing I'll say is that you know I
shouldn't you shouldn't expect to
necessarily find the right answer here
just by kind of intuitive and one of the
points of making things codified in a
Bayesian network is that you don't leave
anything up to your kind of vagueness
it's it's there's actually a correct
answer that we can derive okay so let me
talk about how to go about modeling this
as a Bayesian network so with this
quarry example so there's four steps the
first step is defining what the
variables are okay variables so what are
the variables here yeah
okay so there's a burglary earthquake or
an alarm okay great so these are the
three things that we don't know about
that are mentioned okay so the second
step is you draw some edges okay so
these are going to be directed edges
that correspond to notions of influence
and if you if you want cause causality
but causality is a very more
philosophical thing which we don't
really need for this class so but I'll
bail use it anyway so what causes what
so there's an alarm cause Bullard
burglaries no okay I think it's the
other way around right so burglaries
cause alarm and similarly earthquake
caused alarm and these two aren't I said
they were independent so let's just okay
okay so now I have a direct acyclic
graph that shows how all the variables
are related in some okay so the third
step is to define local conditional
distributions so now I'm going to go one
step further and say how
these are what the probabilities of
these variables are because in the end
remember I wanted to find a joint
distribution of all the variables okay
so I'm going to define a local
conditional distribution for each of
these variables so here I have P of B P
of E and P of a given B so in general a
local conditional distribution is P of
whatever that variable is given its
parents so the parents are the variables
that directly point into it so the
parents of a are B and E he has no
parents and a B has no cats okay
so in particular what I'm going to do is
now let me flush this out I love that
one so what is P of B P of B is a table
that specifies only what's going on in
this region of space so I have B and
have P of B and I just fill out this
what are the possible values of B 0 1 so
let's say you know 1 and 0 so let's say
that probably a burglary is epsilon
epsilon generally denotes a small number
but you hope to be the case on here so
this must be 1 minus epsilon because it
has to sum to 1 and for simplicity let's
say that probability of earthquake is
also epsilon and 1 minus epsilon just
for simplicity and then okay so this
one's a little bit more complicated so
I'm going to write the parents be yi and
the variable itself a and I'm going to
look at probability of a given B and now
I'm going to list out all the 8 possible
combinations here so it's 0 0 0 0 0 1 0
1 0 0 1 1 0 1 0 1 ok ok so for each of
these n you specify the probability so 0
0 0 and I should say that this alarm
system you bought was it's really good
really good so it's um it detects
earthquakes and burglaries are perfectly
okay
so if there's no burglary no earthquake
then the probability of alarm not going
off should be one right it's perfect and
this is the failure case which is zero
because if there's a burglary no
burglary and earthquake the alarm should
be going off and this is I'm not going
to bother you with it DJ I was thinking
you can just fill in the rest of this so
if there's a burglary in a crate that's
strip you maybe someone should check
them doing this right this should be a
wine this should be zero and this should
be a lot something like that okay so now
I have to find the local conditional
distribution so remember I'm not
defining the joint distribution yet I'm
just defining in from zooming in on a
particular variable how does it relate
given its parents right any you can
think about you have a million nodes
I'm only each local distribution might
be only touching it like a very small
part okay so finally the fourth step is
to define a joint distribution okay this
is a thing we're all after right which
is what is the joint distribution over
all three variables here and the joint
distribution is going to be written with
a blackboard P is B equals B e equals e
AE equals a so random variables equals a
particular possible value and this is
defined to be the product of all the
local conditional distributions okay so
P of B P of E and P of a
okay so let me reveal the slide which
hopefully should have the same content
on this one thing I'll point out is that
there is a difference between the small
piece and these big piece so the small
piece or local conditional distributions
these are things that you just define
right there's no right or wrong there
you just define them they're just true
and then there's this big P which is the
joint distribution which is again
defined to be just a product and then
from this joint distribution you're
going to read out things like marginals
and conditionals which might look like
some of these local disc distributions
but they're right now think about them
as distinct objects yeah question so a
question is are we assuming B and E are
independent here so let's see how do I
answer that so yes in this one B and E
are independent and I'll show you a
little bit further how we can kind of
see that more clearly
okay so these are Bayesian networks so
what's the connection between this and
factor graphs
well if you squint a little bit you see
that the right-hand side here is a
product of things and the left-hand side
is this kind of joint you know global
thing and so what does this look like
looks like weight equals product of
factors right so let's go with that
analogy and it's actually much deeper
than a just analogy and let's draw this
as equivalent factor graph okay so for
every Bayesian network we can actually
draw it as a factor graph so here we
have B E and a and okay so now it's you
know it's really important to note that
how did the factors arise through
there's a local conditional distribution
remember for every variable and that is
a factor so for every variable there's a
factor right it's tempting to look at
these edges and draw factors on them but
that's that's wrong okay remember one
factor per variables okay so this
variable has a factor that is P of B
this variable has a factor that's P of E
and this variable has a factor and this
what is this depend on what is its scope
B and E right okay you know again a
common mistake is to just put two
factors here
because it it's really tempting but one
way to think about it is that you know
if you think about your your parents
they are they're married and connected
so that's why these are your parents are
connected actually the I'm not making
this up but there's a some people call
this process moralization yeah to
compute the probability amount water
given just your thing or a properly
given just a burglary yeah so the
question is can you use this compute
probably
alarm given earthquake alone or burglary
alone and the answer is you compute
whatever you want and we'll show you how
to do that
okay so single factor connects all the
parents one factor per variable okay got
it
all right so the Joint Distribution over
all the variables remember is the
product of all the local conditional
distributions and just for reference
this is what it is and now you can go
and answer questions about this so this
is kind of the fun part and I'm not
going to go through the details of how
this is done but I'm just going to show
you a kind of the interface where you
would expect so again this is the
definition of the alarm Network using
the same machinery as a factor graph
because it is a factor graph and first
we're going to ask what is the
probability of B so what is that that
says in the absence of any information
is there a burglary or not okay so what
do you think that should be oh um and
epsilon here is a point zero five so I
think I heard it point zero five someone
said that ok so indeed the probability
of a burglary is point zero five should
be intuitive and now I'll suppose I the
alarm went off okay so now what's a
probability of burglary so what is P of
B given a equals one
let's go up or down should go up if your
alarms working and indeed we see that
probability of burglary given alarm
equals 1 is 0.5 1 and now the monomyth
truth what happens if we condition on
the fact that there's also an earthquake
so let's do this and you get point 0 5
so many of you are correct when you said
that the probability of a earthquake
goes down okay and intuitively you can
think of it makes sense from this
phenomenon called explaining away so
explaining what happens when you have
structures that look like this and you
have suppose you have two causes
positive influencing effect so by
positive influence I mean that if you
flip B equals from 0 to 1 then the
probability of a goes up and so
explaining ways says I conditioned on
the fact conditioning on one cause
reduces a probability of other one okay
so at some level this makes sense
because you know this a is either B or
is either driven by B or e and I don't
know which one it is if I just heard
alarm go on but each of these is very
small problem has very small probability
so the moment I kind kind of see that
one of them explained this cause you see
that one of them is true then I kind of
revert back to the my prior belief on
the you know the other one okay
so humans do this all the time when
you're reasoning when you're thinking
about like well what what causes and you
find one one cause and you discount all
the other ones so now the thing that's
kind of interesting here is that I did
say that B and E are independent which
is also true right so this might have
led people to think like wow it
shouldn't change because they're
independent so why should the
probability change but their key thing
is that when you condition on a you
actually changed the
independence structure of the model this
is why writing things down really
precisely is helpful to kind of
reconcile these seemingly contradictory
intuitions that you might get okay any
questions about this
all right let's move on so we've talked
about the alarm Network this is your
first example of small Bayesian network
hopefully you have an idea of the
intuition behind it so now I'm going to
generalize it and the generalization
shouldn't be surprising so in general I
have n random variables usually denoted
x1 through xn and the Bayesian networks
is a directed acyclic graph over these
variables and it defines a Joint
Distribution over all the variables like
this x1 through xn and this is defined
as a product of local conditional
distributions one for each node ok so
this is a product of all and X i given X
parents of I in this notation just means
the values assigned to the parents of
okay so this is a very general framework
and
just like factor graphs are a very you
know general fabric but the key
difference from factor graphs is the
fact that these factors aren't arbitrary
right there are local conditional
distributions and what does that mean
that means all factors satisfy this
property so if you pick up a factor for
the eighth node P of X i given X parents
is equal to one if you sum over all the
possible value that X I can take
okay that's what it means to be a
probability distribution and this is
true for every setting of X parents
so this property has two implications
which I'll discuss consistency of sub
Bayesian networks and consisting of
conditional distributions and these
properties are going to allow us to
really you know take advantage of the
probabilistic structure when we're doing
inference okay so the first thing is the
question is suppose I have this Bayesian
network this alarm Network and I'm going
to suppose I'm interested in the
marginal distribution of only B and here
okay
I don't care about it so remember this
is the Joint Distribution and by laws of
probability I can derive them marginal
distribution now the question is what
does this marginal distribution have to
do with the Bayesian network the graph
here so let's go through some algebra to
find out so this is a sum over all a and
by definition this is just the product
of all the local conditional
distributions as we just discussed and
now I notice that P of B and P of e
don't depend on a which means that I can
pull this out and push the summation in
that's just a you know algebraic
manipulation and then what is this value
this value is just one because of the
previous slide so I can just drop it and
now I have P of BU times P of E and lo
and behold what is what is this this is
if you had just gone and defined a
miniature Bayesian network over B and E
this was exactly what you've written
down
okay so that's that's kind of cool so
the general idea here is that when
you're marginalizing out a leaf node
that yields a Bayesian network just
without that node so marginalization
produces this this Bayesian network
where you've just erased the theory of
the leaf node along with its incoming
edges right so in other words I've
turned basically what was would have
been a algebraic operation into a
graphical one and generally those are
good moves because it's much easier to
kind of think graphically and make large
operations and go through tons of
algebra yeah definition rules it seems
least for my birthday measures like oh
yeah so the question is what about this
first definition equals what I mean here
is by the laws of probability so it's
not technically a definition it's
follows from the axioms of probability
okay
so notice that in this world P and B and
E are independent so this is one way you
can kind of see that actually when you
define the Joint Distribution in that
Joint Distribution two variables be an
ER independent so one thing to note is I
you know if we looked at the factor
graph you know which is this thing and
remember last time we talked about
marginalization infarct factor graphs
and what does that look like if you what
happens would you if you did
marginalization in this factor graph
okay
yeah you just remove a but this factor
is does it disappear
you
no it doesn't right because factor
garage remember the fact regrets don't
know anything about this factor other
than that it's it's returns non-negative
numbers so you would have to keep hold
on to this factor alright so the moral
of the story here is that if you're
using factor graphs if you convert to
factor graphs too early then you might
lose out on opportunities that really
simplify where if you look at this the
factor graph of this one there is no P
of a given being you right I mean just
to go back here factor graphs will
create a factor which is summation of a
P of a given B and E and call that a
factor and we know because these are
local conditional distributions that's
just 1 so you can just drop it
okay so so that's a first property so
summarize if you marginalize out leaf
nodes you get bayesian networks by just
dropping them from the breath so the
second property is consistency of local
conditionals as I alluded to before if
you have P probability of D given a and
B there's two versions of this that you
can might be thinking about one is a
local conditional distribution which is
again you just define it as such and
then there is the corresponding quantity
that comes about from probablistic
inference so this quantity is derived
from taking the definitions forming the
Joint Distribution and then using the
laws of probability to derive this
particular quantity and this property
says that don't worry about it the two
are equal so you know it means that you
can kind of intuitively think about
they're just so convenient one notion of
probability in your head but I want to
make this explicit but that this is that
doesn't come necessary for free you have
to kind of verify it that this is true
I'm not going to go through the
verification step it's in the notes in
the slides but I'll just state it as
such
okay so let's do another example just to
familiarize familiarize ourselves with
Bayesian networks a little bit more so
the question here is that suppose you
have you wake up and you are coughing
and you have itchy eyes and you're
wondering do I have a cold or do I have
allergies okay
so let's follow this four-step procedure
to define this Bayesian network okay so
step one what are the variables here
there's um
coughing let's denote that as H and
itchy eyes and then cold and allergies
okay so four random variables um how
should I connect these things up yeah so
H and I should be connected to C so if
you have a cold you probably have a
cough and you probably have actually ice
and here you tap into your medical
knowledge and with that
yeah so generally I'm no doctor but
let's just assume for now that allergies
don't really cause a coffee cause it is
probably not true let's just pretend
with us okay so just to make the network
a little bit more interesting okay so
those are the edges and now I have to
specify local conditional distributions
over all of these so what are the local
conditional distributions Pfc you have a
remember one for every node and P of H
given C and over here is P of AI given
CNA right so probability of a node given
its parents and then finally I have the
Joint Distribution which is probability
of C a H I and this is by definition
just the product of everything for this
example I'm not going to go through and
define the actual tables because that's
going to take too much time but I'm
gonna do it in this demo here okay so
this is a Bayesian network that I just
drew on the board and this is as its
associated factor graph remember a one
factor per node yeah points which is eat
the allergies old see a oh yeah right
which one makes sense
so it should be like this and then I
have to adjust things okay
so we're fixing this I give in a and CNA
okay
just for the record I'll just make this
each given CNA and I give in I was into
that okay thanks for catching that okay
so this is the factor graph and let me
show you this demo so you can click on
this and you can see this Bayesian
network in this factor graph and to
answer this question what was the
question the question was if I have if
your coffee and have itchy eyes do you
have cold or allergies so I conditioned
on coffee equals one HDI is equals one
and I'm asking for the probability of a
cold
okay and if you work it out you see that
the probability of a cold is 0.13 and
you know so why does this so okay I
guess I didn't really tell you enough
about the actual prior probabilities so
the probability of a cold is no point
one let's say and the probably of
allergies is point two and then there's
a kind of noisy or where if you're if
you have
a cold or allergies and you you end up
coughing and the if you have each
allergies and you have itchy eyes with
probably point nine and what happened
here is that if you if you condition on
your coughing and you have itchy eyes
there's this kind of interesting
explaining away happening here where you
know even though you didn't observe a
you observe evidence of a and that's
enough to kind of lower the probability
that you have a cold so this is an
example show something a little bit more
subtle how information can kind of
propagate along the Bayesian network in
ways that if you try to do it just time
intuitive that you'll probably not be
able to
okay
so let me summarize so far what we've
done so we've introduced Bayesian
networks where we have random variables
that capture the state of the world and
we have edges between those variables
that represent dependencies between
those variables and based on those
dependencies we go and define local
conditional distributions you multiply
all those local changes show
distribution you get a joint
distribution now without joint
distribution by laws of probability you
can go and ask probabilistic inference
queries and ask questions about the
world given evidence and we saw that
this captures interesting reasoning
patterns such as explaining away and
finally all of this can be brought under
the umbrella of the factor graph
interpretation which we will see is very
useful for actually doing probabilistic
inference in general okay so any
questions before I move on to the next
section
okay so now I'm gonna talk about
probabilistic programs so this is going
to be kind of a little bit of a
whirlwind tour and hopefully give you a
different perspectives and open your
eyes to kind of the possibilities of
Bayesian networks so let's look at this
alarm Network again I can write it as on
the board just a product of all the
local conditional probabilities
basically use math or I can think about
this as a probabilistic program okay so
what I'm gonna do right down is a
program that it's a very simple program
has three lines one for every a variable
and the first lining is B is drawn from
Bernoulli Epsilon so this notation just
means B is set to a random value that
has a distribution Bernoulli Epsilon and
same with earthquake and then finally a
set a equals B or okay and so the idea
here is that a probabilistic program is
just simply a program with randomness in
it that when you run sets the random
variables so this is I think a really
useful way to think about Bayesian
networks and just to maybe very concrete
about this so you can think about
Bernoulli of epsilon is just a Python
program that just returns true with a
probability Epsilon so here random less
an epsilon the random is a number
between zero one has a probability of
epsilon being less than that's all okay
any questions about the what this is
doing yeah
so question is why does ranma's help the
the reason is that I'm want this program
to be put a distribution over possible
assignments every time I run the program
is going to produce a different
assignment and the distribution of that
assignment is the distribution that I'm
defining so this is a kind of an
interesting philosophical point
so normally you run programs and write
programs with intention of running them
and do do something useful but here the
programs are just a kind of an art of
artifact to define a distribution
hopefully this will become a little bit
clearer as I go through more examples
yeah yeah so a question is why don't you
just define a table directly instead of
running this program so the intention
here again is not to run this program
because it's not an efficient way to do
probabilistic inference but it's more of
a metaphor a tool to help you get more
intuition about probabilistic programs
in bayesian networks so hopefully we can
come back to this throw a question after
I go through a few more examples so
here's a more interesting probabilistic
program so suppose you're doing object
tracking and you define a program which
starts with X 0 equals 0 0 so the
initial location is at the origin and
therefore every time step so I'm writing
the program in kind of pseudocode here
with probability alpha I set X I equals
x I minus 1 plus 1 0 so I'm going to the
right and with probability 1 minus alpha
I'm going down ok so now this program
you know that I just described and
induces a particular Bayesian network
structure where each X is only connected
to X I minus 1 ok so what I'm trying to
get you to think about is there's
multiple ways of thinking about
same object and I think when you get
when you can kind of internalize all
these things you kind of get a deeper
understanding of what you're dealing
with right we have the probabilistic of
viewpoint you can look at the table you
can read your equations you have this
graph and now I'm giving you an
additional to all the programs okay so
just for fun you can actually run this
program again this is not what you would
do normally but I can run the program
and okay so every time I hit enter this
gives you a different trajectory so this
is a way to visualize the distribution
over problem X 1 through X whatever how
many of many red squares are okay and if
I change alpha that gives me
distributions which are either skewed to
one side or the other side so that's the
distribution over programs oh sorry
distribution over assignments okay so
what does probablistic
inference look like in this setting so
remember what is probably it's inference
I'm conditioning on some piece of
evidence and I'm asking for the
distribution over some other set of
variables so in case in this case I'm
conditioning on the fact that I spotted
X of the object at a to at time step 10
let's say I'm interested where it could
have been before that so here what I'm
going to do is I'm going to run the
former program and I'm only going to
keep those trajectories and show it if X
10 equals a 2 so if I do that I'm good
at this so this is a 2 I'm seeing that
the set of possible trajectories look
like this so this is the distribution
over trajectories given X 10 equals a 2
okay so in support of what I'm trying to
get you to think about is a Bayesian
network or project program as what is
the distribution you can visualize the
distributions by looking at samples from
that distribution it's another way to
think about right because distributions
are think about like it's suppose you
have a dish I tell you I have a
distribution over images now how do you
actually get ahold of that or understand
that well probably the easier easiest
way is to draw samples from there and
look at kind of types of images that you
get question to specify a distribution
or they like this way to specify
Bayesian action so the question is is
this way a way of specifying a joint
decision by this I mean I guess you mean
the so probably for me in general it is
so so for every probabilistic program it
specifies a joint distribution over the
random variables that you set
and vice-versa if I have a Bayesian
networking and write down a policy for
one thing you know as you'll hopefully
become clear as that the reason to think
about in terms of programs is that you
can inherit all the nice properties of
programs like the ability to find
functions or even have recursion or you
could do a lot more fancy stuff with
programs that you can't do what I mean
which would be hard to do you can think
about Bayesian networks is another way
to think about is I okay you're
basically writing assembly code right
for every variable you specify its value
but if you have a million value of
variables sometimes it's useful to be
able to structure your you know your
code in some way and we'll see that over
the next few examples okay so this is
going to be a march of I think around
seven possible or so possible examples
and just want to give you a flavor of
types of probability programs that were
talking about here so the first one is
called just a Markov and whenever I say
probably program think Bayesian networks
or if generalizations of that so Markov
model so this has a lot of applications
in you know modeling language or time
series and the program works as follows
for every position I through n I'm going
to generate a particular word X i given
the previous word okay so this is also
happens to be the same type of program
as for the object tracking okay so this
is a Bayesian network structure so
here's another one this is called a
hidden Markov model which is it was a
very popular model that was used for all
sorts of things like speech recognition
notably before you know the rise of deep
learning so the idea here is that for
every time step T equals one to T I'm
going to generate an object from
location HT given the previous HT minus
one so this part is just looks like a
Markov
model okay but the reason why it's
called a hidden Markov model is that I'm
not actually going to observe HT I'm
gonna observe sensor readings et at each
time step T given the hidden location
okay so this is what a hit and markov
model looks like sequence of objects
locations we could go observe and sensor
readings which I do observe which depend
respectively on the given object
locations and just as a convention
whenever I shade a variable that means I
you know observe it and if it's not
shaded that means I don't have so that
okay so this program defines a Joint
Distribution over all these variables
and now you can ask particular questions
you can do probabilistic inference and
the most common thing that people do
here is given the sensor readings where
is this object which is something we've
already been exposed to through the lens
of factor graphs but this is again a way
to think about it through the lens of
Bayesian networks so now with this kind
of programming metaphor you can actually
do kind of more complicated things in a
very kind of succinct way so to describe
a multiple object tracking you can think
about there being two objects a and B
and each position each time step and
every object I'm going to generate a
location for the object and this is
going to be two independent Markov
chains which are running but the thing
is that at each time step I only observe
one sensor reading and that sensor
reading is going to be some combination
some function of the actual locations
with all of them a particular time okay
so now hopefully you can see a little
bit of advantage of thinking in terms of
a program because I can write this kind
of a very simple four line program that
very precisely nails down what the
actual model is and in particular this
factorio
hm as it's called is something that
you're going to be exploring you're the
card assignment here's another example
so this is for usually used for
classification it's called naive Bayes I
mean you might have heard of it and the
program looks like this you first
generate a label Y let's suppose you
generate travel and now you're gonna for
every word in your document
you're gonna generate a word given that
label so if you generate travel you
might generate words like these
impairments so now the that again
specifies the distribution over all the
variables what are you typically
interested in if you're interested in
classification you're given the words
and now you want to go back and figure
out what the the classes or give me a
text document what is the label here's a
fancier model of documents called Lane
deer to the allocation so here instead
of have generating a single topic I'm
gonna generate a distribution of our
topics this is getting a little bit meta
because this random variable itself is
actually a distribution but you know
let's not worry too much about that so
this is a distribution and for every
position I'm going to first generate a
topic what like travel or gear up and
then for that topic I'm going to
generate a word given that topic ok so
this allows you to model documents which
talk about multiple things for example
travel in your office ok so this is also
a very popular model that can be used to
if you're given a collection of
documents trying to understand
understand a latent structure inside
so here's one that's kind of a
generalization of the the medical
diagnostics example on the board so in
general let's say you have a bunch of
diseases you generate the activity of a
particular disease in a patient
according to some you know prior
distribution and now you for every
symptom that you might observe or any
sort of lab test you have the
probability of some outcome of that
symptom given the diseases and of course
the probability inference question here
is if a patient has particular symptoms
Wacka diseases does were problems does
he or she okay so I think this is a
maybe the final example here's a social
network analysis example where you have
a set of people each person has you know
a type maybe a politician or a scientist
and these for every pair of people they
can either interact or not interact they
might be connected or not connected
let's say in a social network and so in
the end what you're given is a social
network of connectivity and you're asked
what kind of types of people are there
so generally you you observe maybe some
graph and you want to understand you
know what kind of features or you know
what is what is a concrete way of
summarizing the types of people and
there's this is called a sarcastic block
model but there's other kind of fancier
models database
so that was a very quick overview of
different types of politic programs or
Bayesian networks and there the point is
that there are many many different types
of models that can be written down in
the literature many things generative
models can be just written down in a
project program or equivalently a
Bayesian network and all of them kind of
have this kind of basic structure if you
observe carefully all of them kind of
look like that where is there some set
of variable as H which you don't observe
and that generates or causes a set of
variables which you do observe so the
mindset when you're designing Bayesian
networks is you're coming up with
stories of how the data which you what
you observe was generated through the
quantities of interest to output so this
is probably kind of maybe counter
intuitive and for those of you who are
really used to thinking about just
normal classification where you it's an
opposite you start with the input and
you think about what are things to do to
the input that it can you know what kind
of things kind of do to get it to a
point where I can you know classify on
the input precisely
but Bayesian networks kind of go the
opposite um it starts with the output or
the structure is interested in which are
presumably kind of more um kind of the
Platonic idea or something cleaner and
then you're trying to describe how that
clean data gets or gives rise to this
kind of messy sorry the clean structure
give rise to the messy data that you
observe question right so why is this
call to output so I'm using input/output
here in to borrow terminology for when
we talked about classification where
you're going from input to output input
is what you are given and output is what
your output I guess
producing right and in the the Bayesian
network you first define the model kind
of going from output to end
so kind of an opposite of what you would
normally do and now now there's a second
stage where you do props like inference
which reverses that and you go from the
observations which are the input to the
output which is okay any other questions
about this all right so now let's talk
about inference this is also going to be
the topic of next lecture but I'm just
going to start playing around with this
a little bit so remember what is
probably sick inference we're given a
Bayesian network to find some joint
distribution we're also given some
setting of the variables which is
evidence for example I saw that alarm
went off and I'm interested in a subset
of the variables okay so what I'm trying
to juice is a probability of some query
variables conditioned on evidence and
what this really means is I want this
for all values of the query variables
okay so for example if I have coffee and
itchy eyes to have a cold it's an
example of a probably seen first quiz
okay so let's start with this simple
example suppose I have this Markov model
and I ask this query what is the
probability of X 3 given X 2 equals 5
that condition X 2 goes 5 I'm interested
in X 3 so at this point you already have
the tools to do this and I'm going to
show you how you can just go through the
calculations and then I'm going to show
you an easier way to do this
so if you were just shown this right now
this is probably of what you would do
which might be a little bit tedious
so by laws of probability this or this
conditioning is equal to the joint over
this marginal okay so this is just by
definition of conditional probability
and
one thing I'm going to do here is notice
that I'm only an interest in
distributions over x3 so from that
perspective this blood denominator is
just a constant actually it doesn't
depend on X 3 so what I'm gonna write is
this proportional to which means that
the actual value here is this thing on
the right hand side times some constant
which I don't care about and the reason
I can do this and I don't care about is
because I know that the left hand side
is a distribution so whatever I get on
the right hand side if it sums to 6 or
something then I just divide by 6 and I
get a distribution okay so this is gonna
save you a lot of work if you use a
proportional to song but you have to use
it carefully otherwise you can get wrong
answers ok so let's expand this so this
is a marginal distribution of X 2 X 3 I
can write in terms of the joint where I
sum over the variables I don't care
about so there's again lots of
probability and then the definition of
the Bayesian network here is a joint
distribution is equal to the product or
a local conditional distributions so
right now I have lowercase P now because
they're local distributions now I'm
gonna do some algebraic manipulation so
notice that this stuff doesn't depend on
X 4 so I can push the summation of X 4
over here and then these two first two
terms only these first two terms depend
on X 1 so I can group this and have the
sum over X 1 apply here
and then I can look over here and use
what is this sum to
one second drop it and then what is this
does this depend on X 3 nope so I can
also drop that and I get up here of x3
and x2 equals 5 right so this hopefully
shouldn't be surprising to anyone
because remember that slide when I said
the consistency of local conditional
distributions this is should be equal to
this and this is just one way of
verifying that that's actually the case
for this example okay so no this was you
can do this I mean for this one it's
actually not that bad especially when
you already know the answer but I
promise you there are going to be
situations where you definitely don't
want to grind through all the math
because you can fill up 10 pages of
equations I'm going to show you a kind
of a faster way to do this and so let's
start ok so this is going to be a
five-step procedure but in many cases
not all the steps are necessary and the
key idea is going to be to use the
structure of the Bayesian network and
factor graphs to simplify some of these
operations ok so let's start with ok so
you have X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 step 4 ok all
right so and I'm conditioning on X 2
right ok so X 2 this takes on value 5
ok so this and I'm interested in this
very variable so the first thing I want
to do is I want to remove as many
variables as I can
I just because that's going to simplify
my life so I'm going to remove our
marginalize non ancestors of the query
and the variable I'm conditioning
so by non ancestors I mean anything
that's upstream I am gonna keep for now
anything that's downstream I can let go
okay so what can I remove here x4 right
so I can show this so I think
graphically just remove x4 and that
corresponds to on the slide basically
the fact that this thing sums to one but
I've done this again graphically which
hopefully should be more intuitive okay
so the second step is I'm going to
convert to a factor graph because one
already takes care of and basically I'm
exploiting the properties of Bayesian
networks but after I've done one I don't
it's simpler to think about as a factor
graph where I want to think about of the
factors more explicitly it's just
arbitrary functions and not worry about
which way the conditioning is going
because it's really easy to get confused
by Bayesian networks where you're
wondering like oh this is conditioning
over here what's a marginal distribution
and factor graphs I think by actually
removing the directionality and some
semantics actually make things easier
okay so I'm gonna convert this into a
factor graph which means I have let me
actually just draw it down here again so
here's a factor graph remember I have
all the V of X 1 probability of x2 given
X 1 so this might look like more work
right now because I'm making things
explicit but you can actually do a lot
of these things so remember every
variable has a suti with a factor okay
so
now I want to you know condition on on
the evidence so I'm conditioning on X 2
equals 5 so remember what two
conditioning does remember from last
week's lecture conditioning just removes
this and changes the factors to be each
set to the value that that very exam
yeah oh sorry yeah we shouldn't have X 1
this factor should be there so X 4 is
this is the factor graph corresponding
that okay so I'm conditioning on X 2 so
I wipe X 2 from the face of earth and
I'm going to set this change this factor
to be a partial evaluation of where I
put X 2 plus 5 and this factor is X 2
equals 5 given X 1 ok so this connection
is good so now I can marginalize out the
disconnected components and these are
the components that I'll remember I care
about X 3 so this stuff is disconnected
so I don't care about it so I'm just
going to and that operation corresponds
to the fact that you know this thing
over here I just can draw because it's
not related to X 3 it's just a constant
ok so finally the fifth step is actually
do work ok so what does that mean you
might not be so luckily to be left with
just you know a single variable with a
factor where where that's just the
answer in that case you actually have to
actually compute do the marginalization
operations that we saw last
in this case we are fortunate that this
factor this actually represents the
distribution of X 3 so that is just an
answer to know the problem ok but I'll
go through some of their examples where
it's not
okay so this is just a general strategy
that I outline on the board here and
again I think once you get kind of good
at this you can basically the steps 1 &
4 should be kind of very kind of visual
because you can just see ah
well everything downstream just too
clearly doesn't matter and when you see
these um these are you know conditioning
things you can kind of automatically
just not ignore things and just jump
directly to fire so that's idea I'm just
doing things that are more explicitly on
the board so you kind of see where
things are coming from okay
so I'm gonna do another example
this is alarm so here I have this vision
network and let's blow them interested
in probability of B okay so this should
be a easy one so start with one margin
eyes out non-answer search so which are
the non ancestors
so ane right so I just removed them from
the face of earth and I'm just left with
this single variable B and now obviously
it has a factor of P of B and then I'm
done okay okay so this one's all maybe a
little bit more you know complicated so
this is the probability of earth sorry
burglary given equals one so let's go
through this example try to do it
quickly
all right I'll have a okay so
marginalize out nan ancestor so what I
mean interesting I'm interested in the
probability of B given equals one okay
so I have a and B that I care about so
what are the non ancestors of these
variables there's none right so this is
an ancestor of a so I can't remove it so
can't do anything there too bad
convert to a factor graph we've done
this before probably a fee
Lorelei's the parents so this is
probability of a given B and E and then
this condition on the evidence now so
our condition on a equals one so I'm
going to remove this and change this
factor to a equals 1 given B and E
fourth step is margin eyes out anything
that is distant it nothing's
disconnected so I can't do anything and
rats I have to do actual work okay so
what is actual work mean here I'm
interested in the probability of B so I
need to marginalize out you I have to do
this kind of the hard way based on last
time last lecture so what we're gonna do
here is you know what happens when I
marginalize out e I create a new factor
let me actually replicate this down here
so it doesn't get too confusing so I
create a new factor and this new factor
what's calling F of B which is the
mark-up negative e there's only one
other variable B and this is going to be
the product of all the factors here that
touch this variable that I'm
marginalizing out and the only
difference between this and what we're
doing last time is before we had a max
because we're doing a maximum weight
assignments and here I'm going to have a
sum because we're doing probabilities in
marginalizing so this is going to be
summation over B okay
and then the final query is going to be
just the product of those two things
okay I'm not going to have time to
actually drill down into expanding these
values but if you actually plug in
epsilon into these then you'll find that
the probability of B equals 1 given a
equals 1 is 1 over 2 minus epsilon which
is remember
five one is for epsilon equals 0.05 okay
but this calculation you know you can
look into the slides to see how this is
actually done but it's just algebra
okay so there's another example which
I'm gonna defer to section is to talk
about I think into all of this you just
need to do some practice to get and I'm
comfortable doing these operations to
summarize define Bayesian networks
there's this way of defining models that
allow you to specify locally and
optimize globally once you have a
Bayesian network you can do
probabilistic inference where you
condition on evidence and query
variables of interest and next time
we're going to focus on number five and
hopefully not do things completely
manually but do things more
automatically okay that's it